[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hello, everyone.
My name is Mark Mandel.
I am a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
And I'm here today to
build a multiplayer backend
in four minutes and 51
seconds, sounds like fun?
Cool.
So this very silly game
that I decided to make--
you can clearly see,
I am not an artist--
is called paddle soccer.
It's a two player multiplayer
game, where you're a paddle
and you play soccer.
It's pretty simple stuff.
It has a unity client.
It has a dedicated unity server.
It has some matchmaking code.
And it also has some code that
controls the dedicated game
servers, spinning up
and spinning down,
across a cluster in the cloud.
So how am I able to do that
inside five minutes or three
minutes or so, anyway?
The cool thing that we have--
what I talk about a lot
and what gets me really
excited, is a thing
called software containers.
People here are familiar
with something called Docker?
And some other things like that?
Cool.
So this is particularly
exciting to me,
because the thing that
software containers do,
is enable us to have a
standardization around software
and how we run it.
So regardless of whether we're
running multiplayer systems
or [INAUDIBLE] like
matchmaking systems,
or dedicated game
servers, we can
make software look relatively
the same regardless of like,
how we want to deploy it,
how we want to scale it,
whether we want a
health check, log
aggregation, stuff like that.
That means we can build sort
of generalized solutions
for these kinds of
problems that can
be deployed to almost any type
of software type of problem.
Kubernetes is an open source
container orchestration system
that came out of
Google for doing
exactly these types of things--
deployments, scaling, logging,
all that kind of stuff.
We have a hosted solution at
Google Cloud called Container
Engine, but it's also open
source and can be run anywhere.
So, without further due, let's
actually get stuck into a demo.
Sweet, you've
switched me across?
Perfect.
Excellent.
So I've got a
visualization here.
What I'm going to do here is get
my matchmaker up and running.
I've got some make commands.
I'm going to actually deploy
in front of people, sweet.
So I'll send these yaml
files up to Kubernetes.
And we have a
visualization on top
that shows us the containers
that we're going to be running.
The first thing I'm going to get
is Kubernetes up and running.
It's going to go a
little bit to come up.
Kubernetes.
No, that's not going to work.
For whatever reason
it doesn't like me.
That's fine, it's demo.
It's in front of a lot
of people-- there we go,
there's my read assistance.
Beautiful.
Scrolling.
Of course that's tiny, why not--
because demos in front of loads
of people always go right,
that's fine.
That's fine.
We will deploy-- what I'm
doing now is sending up a bunch
of other yaml files, the
declarative syntax are going
to create a--
five more containers that
are going to fire up for us,
it's going to be a few there.
So we're going to run this
across a series of machines
that we have running
inside a cluster.
Now, we also-- you're
not going to see it here,
but I'm going to deploy
a thing called a service
that then exposes
those matchmaker
clients that are running.
Weavescope's quite nice in
that it will actually show us
the network activity
that is happening
between those machines.
And we have now a
matchmaking system,
we have that up and running.
That's really cool.
What I'm also going to do
is deploy the code that--
the code that organizes
and structures the
dedicated game servers
that are running too.
I'm basically doing
exactly the same thing.
But the cool thing
about this here,
is that this is like 400,
500 lines of code, right?
This isn't a lot
of work that I've
had to do to organize and
orchestrate dedicated game
servers across a
cluster of-- well,
for me it's three
machines, but it could
be up to like 2,000 machines.
This is a lot of work that
I haven't had to do myself,
and it's hugely, hugely
powerful the amount of stuff
I can get to have happen.
So cool, now that's my dedicated
game server orchestration
system, I call it
sessions, for fun.
That's all up and running.
So if I go and say [? qttl ?]
I want to get the IP address.
Of course it's
pending, for two secs.
So I need to get the IP address
of the matchmaking system
as it comes up, so that I
can actually run my game.
There we go, perfect.
So there we go.
There's my IP address.
If I come over here, I
have my client ready to go.
I'm going to run
my game and tell it
where it is that my game server
is running at, which is there.
So we'll still fire that up,
standard unity little window.
Perfect.
Of course it's going to run
full screen, because why not.
I'm going to send that
to another window.
We'll do the same thing again.
That's fine.
That'll connect.
So what should happen here
is now my matchmaking service
is going to say, cool.
I've now got two machines
that are ready to go.
I get one.
I get a ball that bounces, yay.
So we have two players that
are able to play this game.
I flick across, you can see--
yay with the game.
Perfect.
Wonderful.
All right, so--
if this all sounds
interesting we'll be
talking about this more,
Wednesday, 9:30 a.m. at
our sponsored session,
dedicated game server scaling.
We'll also talk about
big data and analytics.
If you can't get to that,
I'm @neurotic on Twitter.
I'll definitely be around.
You can also get this
code at Mark Mandel
slash paddle soccer on GitHub.
Or feel free to reach out
to me and I'll point you
in the right direction.
Finally, thank you very
much for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]